I'm going to use these two as my
examples because each of these is a
different kind of question isn't it
right what kind of answer is going to be
selected out of this wait I catch the
age of the fact it's an objective thing
I think and significantly you're going
to be answering on a scale right like
your ages for you to hear okay so a
scaling a scale is a category of
question now
age age is not the only kind of thing
you could put on a scale right I guess
we would say you could put that on like
a continuum it's like a suit value into
it here here's mine
so I continue is a type of scale type
question did anyone else have any other
kinds of scale type questions that not
actually continue there's a very limited
options okay yeah cousin-in-law and
she's just had like she's literally just
had a seventh child special okay very
good
now this this would be example the
managers game a scale of one to ten or a
scale of one to five or like a very you
know absolutely disagree absolutely like
that type of thing all these have a
column name they're called Likert scales
named after some person who did Cystic
over design li ke RT a Likert scale yeah
you may or may not like it this is often
corner response
so the idea here is it's still a scale
but you may want to actually have
numbers of it like what I say disagree
agree or passionate about etc like
you're not necessarily gonna have what
you do for five but there's still on a
scale or sub card
this are you satisfied question what are
the answers for this yes yes sir no
right so this is part of again this is
part of a category of questions which I
would probably call this twice right
it's like you have to choose now again
for multiple choice so then you can sort
of up again so split apart multiple
choice like AG like people pitcher if
you do society culture you've already
thought about question is I feel like
I'm just it's to death but that's okay
stay with me because my everyone is to
say the are you satisfied a boost yes or
no okay what we call this is a binary
multiple choice question binary that's
just a fancy word by like a bicycle
right it's just there are really two
options right so yes no yes there's the
most common one another one might be
true/false
so if there are only two options that we
call that our binary multiple choice but
of course frequently as we've just been
mentioning there's often more than one
choice or more than two choices I should
say so if you've got more than two more
than two options again there's a cover
difference you could do this one other
ones I did get to show you was um if you
are talking about are who would I vote
for right it's like well I might be able
to I might be happy to vote for several
different things so you like check
multiple boxes within your multiple
choice right and we're OK to accept
multiple answers whereas other times
it's like you're either this way that
now if you're either this or that or
which
we would call that an exclusive choice
one choice excludes all the other ones
so you have to be this or that but not
both at the same time and of course if
you're happy to choose more we would
call that non exclusive thank you so
we've got our multiple choice we're
going to scales there's one more it's
the kind of question which I'll kill
you've been trying to avoid do it
explain what it is the kind of question
you'd be trying to dog into your I was
gonna say open-ended yeah very good
everyone that seems a quad they just
give them as ridiculous answers it's
like let students actually say something
and they'll say something another way of
saying that is free response